also beantworten waren an alle
journalisten da draußen sie beantwortet
ist jetzt braucht es nicht noch mal
fragen entlang und
[Musik]
willst du mein video beginnen ja
hallo herr
original
ich bin die synchronstimme von celle
jetzt ist es raus nach all den jahren
eigentlich kann ich gar nicht kochen und
backen das macht alles nicolet ihren
deswegen sind wir in manchen sequenz
noch immer nur hände
sorgt aber ich meine dass ich aus meinem
körper du bist total heute habe ich die
schürze auf teilige gründen weil ich nie
bisher ließ manchmal immer so ein
bisschen opulenter aussehen soll
ich freue mich dass ich heute schon
wieder hier sein da ich ja mal hinterher
radio und heute ist es ja ein ganz
besonderes video weil heute abend
passiert was heute abend läuft unsere
gemeinsame folge shopping queen spezial
und die läuft um 20.15 also falls ihr
heute nennen ihn halt anders ihr müsst
heute abend den green schaut egal was
ihr vorhabt egal auf welches konzert auf
welcher hochzeit auf welche
veranstaltung eingeladen seien alles
absagen kann ist jetzt 21 15 shopping
für richtig und ich vielleicht zur
erklärung ich wurde eingeladen so die
verwendung und ich hab sie direkt mit
reingezogen war so mitgehangen
mitgefangen der redaktion direkt gesagt
fragt sich klar dass irgendwann sagen
damit ihr und habe hier ganz kurz
geschrieben und sie hat direkt gesagt
sie ist mit dabei
eine woche hamburg gemeinsam erleben und
die sendung wird lustig als sie wird
mehr als lustig garantiert ich hoffe
sich schnell in die knaller mit rein
findet sie mal das war schon knaller
wenn die im nachgang noch mit rea
jedenfalls läuft die sendung heute abend
es ist eine lange folge sind vier
kandidatinnen und wir hatten viel spaß
und wir uns gedacht wenn man schon eine
zutatenliste auch veröffentlicht wie vor
ein paar tagen
und wenn ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr
heute abend gemeinsam mit euren freunden
partnern familie wie auch immer was
leckeres zubereiten und dann 20 50 15
pünktlich vorm fernseher sitzen und
alles zusammen naschen er super lecker
sind noch machen sie schnell und einfach
gemacht und so zum snacken auch noch so
far so ein bisschen was ungesundes
bisschen was gesundes bisschen was käses
also richtig lecker und wir starten
jetzt gleich mal mit dem ersten rezept
und das hat überbackenen nachos
richtig quote so und und
heute sehr heiß
wir können nicht kochen wenn der kleinen
kammer an deswegen mache ich jetzt immer
mal schön paloma hey was ist ein kleiner
mann beim trinken hallbauer
normalerweise mit tequila wir machen es
jetzt mal ohne ihr wissen wollt ihr noch
hier schön durch und hat noch ein
bisschen was voraus und wenn man sich
jetzt einfach mal noch schnell
wurden das schöne leben
ich bin so verliebt integrierter ich
musste einfach hier richtig schön ins
bild reinräumen was brauchen wir denn
dafür warum
soll ich dir auch auspressen die limette
weil ich kann keine frau die hat den
besten zitronen limetten presse auf der
ganzen welt
beim umzug weggekommen ich sage dann
regeln würde ja ist leider weggekommen
kriegst du sie verstecken die treten im
fernsehen hier also die hansa-kogge ist
es wie bei qvc diese gläser sind von
meiner freunde fällig die sind
wunderschön und ich finde diese
zitronenpresse die braucht einfach mal
gerade ihre ehren sekunde das ist die
beste zitronenpresse wo gerät ist so
geil die ist so richtig stabil da könnt
ihr alles mit ausquetschen und die ist
der hammer spiel fertig
den link blende ich euch unten ein es
ist ganz wichtig sind auch wenn du mal
nicht mehr auf tour gehe ist ganz recht
dass dieser echt viel auf tour gehen auf
tour finde ich schon können dass du für
mich in eigenen shopping kanal machen
ich mache nur deinen job ist jede jedes
wort was ich spreche da sonst jedes
video jedes produkt du weißt wie man es
benutzt
durch das einpressen schauen
das ist doch mal direkt für super so er
ist davon so ein bisschen wasser macht
so brandt aus braunem zucker mit ein
bisschen flirten und chili die höchste
scharfen heißt und ist
dann gehen wir noch ein special ins glas
gehen ein bisschen salz dazu den
grapefruitsaft und ein bisschen zäh wir
nehmen jetzt aber ergaben dicksaft das
nicht auch sehr gut hören das ganze mal
um impuls und roda auf und dann das okay
und im original kommt auch der
kinderkanal
ja man könnte den trinkern mit
blutorange machen und auf definieren
allein das ist schon so hübsch aus du
hast du das rein getunkt zum fixen hier
das feuer brauner zucker blödeste und
und als hätte das ist der zucker city
restaurant der grip was nimmst du als
alternative wenn man mal kein zucker
sirup hat daheim irgendwann das wasser
und ein bisschen zucker mischen oder sie
kommt auch wasser und wo nicht was im
augenblick alles verpflegt und kommt
[Applaus]
nicht so
richtig gute dennis weis hat was gut ist
noch barkeeper
besitzt der grapefruitsaft hier das
wahrscheinlich peter
mittlerweile sind nicht mehr so wie
früher war das ist genau nicht studieren
beginnt deswegen liebe ich grapefruit zu
essen mit salz drauf ja auch drauf strom
oder krieg schon eröffnet uns war sein
und zusammen es geht auch mit mit orange
manchmal lässt
das ist irgendwie
eine prise salz keine gläser sind so
schön ich kann mir
also richtige barkeeper machen das ist
so eine ellenlange
just so
much songtext
x.de
ja nicht nur ein stäbchen
cocktails
wie tequila würde man jetzt noch mal
reinmachen prozent lieber würde man
sagen
zwecken einfach so eine great für die
scheibe
sie sieht auch so schön aus
die gewinne daraus donnerstag
dafür aus nach wie der schnitt von tom
sagt nicht mehr ich habe so etwas noch
nie gesehen
keine lohn wird aus wenn du gerne genau
stellen gesunken
im schnitt von einer summe
doch so schmücken dann
entsprechend
recherchen bin ich erst mal umrühren
hast du schnell bist du später dabei bei
unseren fernseher abend
20.45 uhr sendet weißt was glaubst du
hättest der box wer gewinnt ich will zu
spalten zu trauern jetzt natürlich bei
gewöhnlichen nicht mehr auch in queens
danke dennis
verbrennung bei uns wirklich ganz stark
meine stimme lauschen garten
voll erfrischend
was seinen sommergetränk
ist genial wir genießen den drink und
zeigen euch kurz die zutaten für die
überbackenen nachos
für die überbackenen abschuss verwenden
wir 500 gramm hackfleisch ist vom rind
etwas olivenöl ne zwiebel und
knoblauchzehe tomatenmark paprikapulver
kreuzkümmel salz und pfeffer dann haben
wir hier eingelegte rapelius cheddar
käse
topteam chips 200 gramm und für den
salat für oben drauf haben wir hier
einfach nur frühlingszwiebel tomaten
aber carlos etwas koriander eine limette
und natürlich auch salz und pfeffer okay
wir starten erst mal mit der pfanne da
können wir mit max die pfanne erhitzen
dann traten war das hackfleisch mit
olivenöl und eigentlich wie beim start
bei einer polonaise das webel und
knoblauch schälen und schneiden mit
anbraten so isch zwiebel knoblauch
machen gerne ich überlasse ich
nochmaliger verdonnert jeweils nochmal
meinen koriander wird ja das ist so eine
sache in meinem körper mit dem koriander
ich mag kein koriander kann da ich kann
das auch nicht also ich kann nicht sagen
ich mag es nicht ich kann es nicht es
kann ist das kann ich mal in die nähe
von meinem gesicht gehen es ist ganz
schlimm für mich bei mir ist koriander
aus unding so ganz wenig ist okay ich
weiß dass es hier perfekt dazu passt wir
legen sie einfach nur als deko drauf
glaubst du an diese theorie mit dem
koriander das schon da manchen leuten
näher wird aufgrund der gene ich glaube
ich schon ich mag es einfach nicht das
gleiche zuerst am briten zu zerstören
und hast du meine
kinder kannst du dir waka waka ja ja der
zerdrückt das voll gut
er macht immer schön krümelig
und bei seinem kochabend kochst du gerne
mal mit freunden oder für kochs zu leben
ich bekomme lieber ich bin auch keine
also lasst uns mal über das beispiel
über dieses romantische beispiel
sprechen diese ich habe gesagt und ich
koch mit denjenigen gemeinden mit nee
ich möchte doch nicht ich kann das mit
jemanden wo ich weiß der ist auf meinem
level auf meinem tempo her aber es gibt
ja auch leute also nichts gegen anfänger
ich finde jeder sollte versuchen zu
kochen und ich bin jetzt auch total
schön aber wenn man gerne brocken und
auch zügig kauft kann sowas auch schon
mal ein bisschen aufhalten ja das muss
man dann schon so zelebrieren und
danach mit einem schönen ring dabei aber
ich habe lieber alles fertig bevor die
gäste kommen und überrascht mit seiner
tafel so können wir heute so machen wie
er möchte entweder könnt ihr kochen oder
ihr kind gemeinsam wir hatten neulich
tatsächlich einen gemeinsamen kochabend
da haben wir unseren talker er hatte
geburtstag im märz da haben wir so einen
kochabend arrangeur sie hat heimischen
panisch
war schön es war richtig schön und daran
glaube ich schon alles so auf einem
level uns hatte halt einfach spaß macht
alles vorbereitet und zwar richtiges
chaos aber wir kamen
gerne
das heißt wir machen jetzt aber
hackfleisch krümelig anbraten und dann
zwiebel knoblauch dazu mit braten und
dann wirklich mit tomatenmark salz
pfeffer
kreuzkümmel und caprica abschmecken
so ein bisschen mexikanisch heute ich
will aber jetzt auch nicht sagen dass
wir heute und mexiko abend haben denn ja
dann führt dazu dass man sagt mexiko ist
nicht so texmex also wir sagen einfach
so spanisch mexikanisch inspirieren ja
rezepte von uns da kommen wir glaube ich
nicht in teufels küche als auch jeden
fall bis hin zu haben
ist ja immer so wie wenn wir auch was
türkisches kochen und dann kommen die
griechen und sagen nö waren wir dann
kommen die araber sagen das waren wir
haben wir immer ein bisschen kleinen
disput
ja aber ich sage immer ist egal wo es
herkommt ihr habt was schmeckt lecker
und essen verbindet ja hast du schon mal
die frage beantwortet was mein
leibgericht ist
das ist eine klassische interview frage
was ist für die klassische
interviewfrage bei dir was ist dein
lieblingsessen was ist dein
lieblingskuchen wer ist das alles wann
hast du mit dem backen angefangen
okay okay also bat worten an alle
journalisten da draußen sie beantwortet
ist jetzt die braucht es nicht noch mal
fragen entlang und meine leibspeise ist
manchmal habe ich keine
aber meistens schon eigentlich gern
lasagne und spaghetti bolognese ja wie
machst du die lasagne also aus meiner
bolognese
weißt du dass diese zehn jahren hat das
kleine frikadellen machen und die dann
vergrößern also ich glaube ihr lieben 17
jahren
ich glaube dass ich habe mal ein
ein rezept video gesehen wo behauptet
wurde dass die sizilianische bolognese
aus kleinen frikadellen gemacht würden
die werden dann fällt also nicht quasi
aus lemgo
so
ja als ich habe okay ich werde anfang
mai wahrscheinlich wieder nach sizilien
mal gucken aber ich habe eigentlich ja
labbadia ist jetzt gerade wieder so mein
aktuelles lieblingsvideo aber auch
elektrisiert immer ja ich esse einfach
gemüse
mein leibgericht der stadt sehr gerne
gulasch jetzt ein gutes drin laguna
stetig erst aber auch gerne gute bologna
werfen früher immer eine polonaise tag
morgen ist ja donnerstags habe ich
spaghetti bolognese okay ich bin im
haushalt groß geworden wo es seitdem ich
denken kann freitags immer was mit
nudeln gibt meine eltern mussten
frühjahr freizeit es immer lange
arbeiten dann muss das irgendwas geben
was schnell geht seit ich denken kann
essen meine eltern frei sagt immer
irgendwas mit pasta ok
hinzu dass coolere er nicht so super
liebe ich auch
liebe pasta es sind seine typischen
interview fragen
kannst die unangenehmen weg lassen auch
sind da keine unangenehmen aber
was ist denn jetzt los zwischen mann und
frau wo ist das problem
in einem satz beantworten könnte
wie kam das eigentlich mit dem deutlich
donnerstag das ist eine frage die man
haben
und was ist die klassische frage die die
jemals bei dritte donnerstag gestellt
wurde ich finde also wenn ich menschen
kennenlernen
jetzt auf events zb irgendwelche stars
oder wikis ich fragte ja dann auch wie
kam sie zum sport oder wie aber dann
lernst du ja da die menschen kennen und
du weißt ja vorher vielleicht oft gar
nicht wen du triffst aber ich finde wenn
man jemanden interviewt ja dann finde
ich müssen diese klassischen fragen
einfach wegfallen weil das kann man halt
eigentlich über uns lesen ja und weiß wo
wir das auch aufgefallen ist extrem
diesen
erfolg kling für die griffe ich auch zu
hause habe und liebe ich habe es den
brink die
anderen auch starte hier
als die no angels sich wieder
zusammengetan haben ja letztes jahr da
waren die eher gefühlt bei jedem
interview was es gibt und nach
anderthalb jahren wurden sie immer noch
gefragt wie ist das eigentlich gekommen
bei euch wieder zusammen getragen und
wenn ihr jemanden gerne mag und guck dir
viel material von demjenigen an und du
siehst den interviews von der see dann
siehst du auch erzählen interviews wenn
man 90 prozent die fragen wie du schon
hundertmal beantworten das meine ich
wenn ich mich auf ein interview
vorbereitet finde ich sollte man andere
fragen stellen soll manchmal ausmachen
oder noch was rein weil sonst
die lüftung raus und eigentlich dass
ganz ausmachen
und ich schneide hier nebenher tomaten
und die frühlingszwiebel für den salat
oben brauchen
was riecht schon so lecker und
ist aber was wir sehr gut vorbereiten
könnt denn wir werden das ist hier alles
auf diesem ofen blech anrichten und
später wenn alles andere auch fertig ist
einfach den ofen schieben dann ist es
später noch war jeder hase flüssig was
kann man noch ganz lecker mit hähnchen
machen oder wenn ihr wollt auch vegan
mit vega lag ich kann mir das gut
vorstellen mit auberginen oder zucchini
mediterran angehauchte
wenn du magst du erstmal abspecken
probieren aber gern
das ist gar nicht gut
[Musik]
bin ich aus dem bild nein
ich hab noch nicht probiert aber bei mir
fehlt das schon sagen
also ich dir einfach alles in würfelchen
da kommt es da rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also wir beide quasi geschlossen wir
lassen koriander weg es bei uns nur
reden ja aber für die liebhaber die
stehen ja total hat sich das ist super
es schon immer schon anrichten gerne
einfach über den hotspot ich habe
übrigens auch gelernt dass dort ihr das
sind die tortilla chips und so bald war
es mit käse überbacken ist oder mit käse
getunkt und übergossen wird heißen totti
as nachos ist es so viel sagen na chips
aber dessen smarties erst wenn der käse
quasi traurig also ist das quasi wie bei
einer cassidy ja das end gericht genau
also hier der salat mit orangenen wollte
sagen olivenöl und limettensaft und
später einfach mit salz und pfeffer dann
stelle ich den jetzt zur seite und
sobald du hier
den das land oder
da kommen jetzt noch die kampagne von
käse drauf und später wird es einfach
nur noch im ofen überbacken und so kann
man es wirklich perfekt vorbereiten für
sonnabend salat stellen als auch zur
seite und dann können wir jetzt gleich
nämlich noch popcorn machen sich die
würze gedeck dann machen wir wilde
maiskolben super
käsekuchen freue ich mich ja jetzt im
raum
ich würde vorschlagen den kiesigen athen
ist der braucht ja wahrscheinlich auch
am längsten von allen
ich liebe es intelligent davon ja das
heißt damit fangen wir an dann ist auch
alles zeitgleich werte ja und ja ich bin
natürlich auch ganz aufgeregt dass ich
mit der käsekuchen backen war für mich
käsekuchen ja schon in der 7 das
highlight ist und ich glaube alle
käsekuchen backen kann habe ich von dir
gelernt von deiner video ja ja ja eines
der
videos sich am meisten geschaut hat von
dir ist der new york cheesecake mit dem
store berlin das ist aber auch schon
sehr alt schon von der von der alten
küche aber da hab ich das glaube ich so
richtig raus gehalten den käsekuchen mit
dem video von meiner freundin
also käsekuchen soldaten
für den käsekuchen nehmen wir 425 gramm
frischkäse 250 gramm quark 150 gramm
puderzucker
360 gramm stärke vanille extrakt und
entweder nehmen die jetzt eine zitrone
mit zitronen abrieb und saft oder
einfach zu drohen passte zwei rollen
großer tag sind zucker und flüssige
butter okay das sind die zutaten für den
käsekuchen überschaubar oder total also
dann kannst du gerne hier alle
käsekuchen zutaten verrühren heute habe
ich bin
sprachfehler warum machen wir das heute
nicht in der maschine
können wir auch aber und ist es so dass
du nicht zuerst mit dem zucker anfängst
und hinterher sondern was alles zusammen
hier weil ist wurscht ist egal und es
soll gar nicht so schaumig gerührt
werden sondern einfach creme weil der
käsekuchen einfach nicht luftig wirken
und krieg
ich würde vielleicht die kurz vorher
gerne auch schneebesen und so wie du
magst und ich kann so lange ich glaube
ich habe noch nie fertig im video
benutzt aber es wird halt muss ich sagen
bei seinem kers kuchen echt den rahmen
sprengen wenn ihr jetzt her kommt und
sagt er macht jetzt großen tag selber
ich finde dafür lohnt sich's einfach
echt nur dann noch module
und es wird ein käsekuchen der oben und
unten eine kruste bekommt mit zimt
zucker dann ist es so ein bisschen auf
ja wir machen das so noch nie dem
stimmte wollte noch was mit ich wollte
noch ein bisschen was fruchtiges dabei
habe ja
und leckeren
ja wir machen noch und der platz ist
hier
also ich bereite ich jetzt eine rolle
aus auf dem
auf dem gleich
was
für ein doppel sie dazu jedes mal wenn
ich komme gibst du mir hier so eine
frühe arbeit
weil ich nicht hatte gefrorene früchte
oder irgendwie normal was machen dann
erbt werden wie die soße von new york
cheesecake thomas habe ich nur erdbeeren
gefrorene erdbeeren denn derzeit ist
ist es so ich hatte so die letzten loch
die walderdbeeren im garten aber jetzt
ist erdbeerzeit für garnier
arbeitszeiten ja
was sind jetzt wieder los der aber auch
die deutschen erdbeeren es gibt es keine
deutschen opfer es ist so ja gern hätte
klaus hat keine mehr zu den klaus musst
du mal kennen lernen
dass unser bauer hier sehr nett aber
klaus
also der wirklich auch mögen obstbauer
spargel
erdbeeren und der beliefert alle und
habe das auch eine eine klausel frau das
so ok person zweck klausel schon was
wirklich wie ein ist denn klaus klaus
sie ist mitte fünfzig
gut gebaut ein ja von kartoffelbauern
ich träume von einem kartoffelbauern
aber da sagt man doch bitte beachten
müssen ja aber ich ja aber schon mal
kartoffelbauern wir die zum beispiel
ihre kartoffeln an an so fast food
restaurants für pommes verkaufen oder
zum beispiel ein schiff companies
dubai erdbeerbauern ist auch gläubig ist
es so bis zu dem tag wo sie abgeerntet
sind hier der kartoffelbauer hat immer
was zu tun
ich nehme schon klausel
dass stärke speisestärke und darum sehe
noch keine letztes für die bindung und
zitronen passte und hier könnt ihr den
teig eine rolle einfach hier verteilt
und immer ein bisschen flach drücken
denn die naht vom grossartig muss ein
bisschen verschlossen werden dann legte
ich hier den rahmen außen rum
es ist unser erster gemeinsamer
schießkino ich freu mich so sehr
also mein tipp für die zuschauer ihr
könnt daheim auch mit der maschine
machen ja hier steht ja eine maschine
wir hätten das ist halt weil die frauen
nicht 100 maschinen hätte aber weil aber
heute ist die blätter und die bringt ja
immer außerdem ist kraft mit außerdem
will ich mit ihr unterhalten ja ja und
das war was zu tun haben
sondern ein paar internas auspacken von
shopping gewinnen gab über das thema
sprechen also stell dir einfach eine
frage und domi ok www verraten nicht das
motto mit davon leider nicht wie es aus
könnte heute abend redet man nicht und
im nachgang könnt ihr natürlich gerne
mal und das video schreiben wir euch die
sendung gefallen hat aber wie stressig
fandest du jetzt im nachgang deine
shoppingtag gott ich fand es
sehr stressig da hat er viele stunden
aber effektiv hast halt keine 4 es ist
halt genau vielleicht können wir den
mythos ja mal auf deck genau wir denken
dass jetzt mal auf du bekommst morgens
wir hatten ja vier shopping tage jeder
waren im anderen tag dran und du
bekommst morgens sein motto und dann
musst du noch kurzen interview abgeben
und dann düste los und du hast ab dann
vier stunden zeit fahrzeit wird
mitgerechnet die ganzen schnittbilder
werden mitgerechnet sich hier ein das
heißt alles was so im hintergrund
passiert und quasi der zeit raubt wird
alles mit gerechnet das heißt effektiv
hat man ohne scheiß eigentlich nur 22
stunden ja und dann fährst du quasi vom
laden noch zum anderen laden dann
vielleicht noch zum stylisten und du
hast echt also maximal 2 es gab keinen
promi-bonus da hatte ich darauf gehofft
eine kleine axt dran weiß was dafür was
da für verkehr ja also ich glaub ich
zehn minuten gebraucht in die stadt und
bei uns franz 30 ja das war schon das
schon mies also da muss ich echt sagen
dass kommission habe ich schon gedacht
so ein bisschen können wann bodens
machen
also es war schon aber dadurch dass ich
einen laden gefunden habe der zum glück
schuhe hat accessoires taschen war für
mich zum glück dann so dass ich gesagt
okay ich hätte eigentlich noch ein zwei
dinge gebraucht aber dann hat mir die
zeit nicht mehr gereicht ja man muss
vielleicht auch dazu sagen wir haben ja
in hamburg geschockt alle kandidaten und
keiner von uns ist hamburgerin gewesen
ja bedeutet wir haben uns auch shop
technisch sehr auf die produktion
verlassen
also wir konnten jetzt nicht sagen ob
ich kenne hier so ein paar shops so
gerne einkaufen würden sondern also
durften wir schon aber vielleicht kannst
du den nächsten meetings aufdecken darf
man denn in jedem laden ja das fragen
sich ja auch viele also man braucht
natürlich eine drehgenehmigung und
gerade in so großen ketten ist das
unmöglich die möchten das nicht oder
fähig ist auch so schwierig sei mit
genehmigung zu bekommen und deswegen und
was finde ich auch eigentlich ganz schön
konzentriert sich die produktion dann
hat er auf zu kleinere boutiquen und
ja und in so einer kleinen boutique ist
es natürlich dann auch noch mal ein
bisschen schwerer weil wenn ich zu hause
weiß ich ganz genau worauf hängt hier
könnte vorweg schon mal so ein bisschen
stöbern und wenn du in eine unbekannte
kleine boutique gehst in der hoffnung
dass die auch noch deinen motto
vertreten hier schon schwierig und dann
kann es natürlich auch sein dass du da
anrufs vorher also die produktion muss
ja vorher anrufen und fragen dürfen wir
da rein und diesmal filmen und die
verraten dann den laden schon das motto
wie zb keine ahnung
[Musik]
hochzeiten und dann sagen wir haben was
klappt es mit vier modellen empfinden
vielleicht ob sie daran ja das ist so
wie immer für dich da shopping day
entspannt für mich ich habe auch in
einem laden alles gefunden fast alles
ich glaube ich war in zwei geschäften
der verkehr hat auch mitgespielt
und
ich war sehr konzentriert also ja ich
habe nicht lange gefackelt ich bin in
das geschäft und ich habe mich wirklich
auf das thema konzentriert und auch die
kleidungsstücke
ich hatte murat und
[Musik]
die beste schoppen begleitung dapd
wenn man eben was zu essen kauft dabei
ja
ich musste ein bisschen budget natürlich
war der hunger bekommen mittendrin hat
er gegessen mit diesen
hier der käsekuchen unser gedeckt da
guck mal da wird schon abgedeckt mit dem
teig also unter der käsekuchen mast und
obendrüber kommt jetzt der kronzeugin
und dem muss man so ein bisschen drücken
tatsächlich damit der
traum jetzt gleich oder das darfst du
gerne mal hin hier ist die butter drauf
und zimt zucker und dann kommt schon
offen easy oder auch nach stunden
dreiviertel jahr so 45
das passt
[Musik]
april offen gerne und während der pakt
bereit nur noch zwei drei andere sein
magst du mir den öffentlichen
[Musik]
facebook korn nehmen 40 gramm
sonnenblumenöl 100 gramm popcorn sie
haben eine gewürzmischung nämlich salz
zwiebel und knoblauch pfeffer
paprikapulver des geräuchert oregano und
chili und dann noch zum karamellisieren
etwas zucker erfahren dicksaft butter
und zum abschmecken limettenschale ag
ja ich muss gestehen ich habe dieses
popcorn ja schon mal beide gegessen
und auch wenn das bei der zutaten
zusammenstellung vielleicht ein bisschen
ja noch nicht vorstellbar klingt ich
verspreche es euch das ist so lecker
schmeckt so gut aber ich bin gespannt
wie du es machst weil
wenn man sich auf trip talk zb umschaut
wie man popcorn geschmack gibt da gibt
es die dollsten theorien die ganz oft in
die hose gehen ja deswegen zeigt es uns
ja also popcorn habe ich schon mal auch
beim kanal gemacht ihr könnt im topf zu
bereiten oder verdi kennen wird einfach
in der kenwood denn ihr braucht dort
nämlich nur sonnenblumenöl oder hoch
erhitzt bares öl und popcorn eis im topf
klappt es ganz gut da schaut euch
einfach mein anderes video an wir machen
jetzt einfach hin erkennt ja dass wir so
ein bisschen mehr zeit für alles andere
haben ich habe ich nämlich so ein
programm
da kann ich hier auf popcorn gehen die
erhitzte bis 180 grad und dann macht es
hier innerhalb von fünf sechs minuten
richtig schön pro konnten das kommt hier
rein und dann kannst du gerne in der
zwischenzeit den zucker in der pfanne
karamellisieren
und es klingt wirklich komisch finde ich
die mischung so süß salzig scharf aber
es ist echt lecker gaben tipps geben wir
gleich dazu
und hier aber hinterher und hin zum pop
corn mais aber noch das öl
[Musik]
ok also bald popcorn so im
gegen ende des satzes das karamell
machen also jetzt einmal getoppt nie
mehr gestoppt es war aber nicht vom top
conti werk war wirklich top rangliste
hatte noch richtig pop sofa nein
wer von den zuschauern kenntnis pop sofa
von weber das schmuddelige
dass sich anke engelke gemacht
besucher herzlich ein verändertes staat
als mitte 20 jährige
aber gut wenn wir lang ist es her sein
aber hey wir sind der gleiche jahrgang
20 jahre 25
ganz bestimmt
ich kann es nicht aber ich gebe hier
schon mal die gewürze rhein in der große
schüssel
und einzug das nicht auch gut aus
und ich schreibe noch die limettenschale
magst du im kino eher süß oder salziges
volk gemischt nicht und das wird so sein
ding also wenn leute das noch nie
gegessen haben soll sich um süßes
popcorn gemischt die müssen das
probieren das ist so mega deswegen liebe
ich daraus lautet arena
das ist unser super kombi schuhkarton
ok ich glaube mein ton ist das
hier auch gleich und dann einfach
ergaben dicksaft dazu butter dazu
popcorn darin schwenken und fertig was
glaubst du wird heute abend auf
highlight in der sendung die
siegerehrung
die wird wie soll ich sagen
ganz interessant werden ich würde sagen
sie wird unerwartet sehr unerwartet
und so ja wir dürfen das motto natürlich
nicht verraten von der sender aber
offensichtlich kennen wärs ja wie tanzen
das motto
schwierig ich fand's motto
sehr offen und dann aber wieder doch
sehr beschränkt du
ja also für mich war es ja die hölle
dass man auch in der sendung
wahrscheinlich sehen für mich war dass
ich fange es die anderen tage also wir
hatten ein großes gemeinsames motto und
dann hatten wir jeder für sich einfach
noch mal so einen zwischen motto ja so
wie wenn man jetzt sagen würden das
motto ist fasching und karneval und
bereitest dich hier in die richtung und
du in die richtung wie so ein großes
ding und dann so zwischen und ich fand
seine mutter fand ich eigentlich schön
aber schwierig das motto von susanne
fand ich hammer das war das coolste
motto ja meine lieblings motto hat sie
ja immer noch
nie so wie ja ich fand der jsg mainz
gewesen und meine mutter mit dem konnte
ich gar nichts anfangen aber gut aber
dafür war es schade super umgesetzt ja
soll ich mal jetzt dass ihre aktion als
um die ohren
ja mach ich mache aus schön aufpassen
mit karamell
karamell ist so heiß meint man da nicht
mehr da kann man sich so richtig alles
daran verbrennen
anna kommer da rein
hier ist popcorn
giftmörderin
[Musik]
also bei dir ist alles soweit dann gehen
wir pokern dazu
schwenke das durch damit dem ganzen
gewürzen und fertig ich habe hier noch
ein paar ich glaube dir tu ich noch mal
rein
ich finde ja auch sowieso wie viele
folgen shopping queen gibt es schon gibt
es das schon seit zehn jahren zehn jahre
war dieses jahr
2010 jahre special in der türkei dabei
was viele ja nicht wussten das war mal
ein türkisches format und dann hat
deutschland gekauft und deutschland
hinaus zu reparieren oder gern auch vom
türken aber deutschland ist das einzige
land das seit zehn jahren shopping quinn
hat weil guido maria kretschmar das eben
gut macht und er ist häufig gespurt
konstant hält aber ich muss auch sagen
irgendwann gehen eigentlich die shopping
themen aus also ganz ehrlich aber unser
thema war echt so
schwierig da die lassen sich ja schon
immer irgendwie was war
da ist ja manchmal sorgt dabei ja aber
was haben sie sich gedacht die machen
wir fertig die leute das haben sie sich
richtig gedacht ich glaube ich mal
kleine noch eine portion popcorn habe
das reicht uns noch niemals gehört abend
mache mir meine jungs wir machen gleich
nochmal passiert ja da würde ich sagen
machen wir nur noch um für einen salat
fertig bitte meist folgen und richten
alles an
[Musik]
hallo mora sesam öffne dich
so weihnachtlich oder gut aus das nun
richtig schön ist so eine richtige das
mal an
und jetzt schneiden wir die inso
schnittchen oder wir machen wird genau
aber wir lassen den jetzt erst mal
komplett abkühlen ja dann raus lösen und
den schnittchen schneider ja
wir haben so viel in der küche stehe ich
weiß nicht mehr wohin wir packen den
daraus
also wir sind jetzt wir sind hier noch
beim salat tragen wir haben so eine
allerlei würde ja sagen ich dachte du
machst den salat man gerne ich mache
alles an was
es liegt
in meinem in meiner dna und was machst
du was ich höre ich sie tina zu ihm
gehören mit dem käse
das dressing einfach drüber ok also
nochmal für die zuschauer hier sind drin
frühlings 7 paprika kidney bohnen mais
und
[Musik]
ja also wir haben in der zwischenzeit
den verrat geschnippelt verfassen
manchmal lese ein bisschen limette
weißem balsamico muss leider alle teile
jetzt rausschneiden aus dem video weil
wir zu viele interna verraten haben ja
viele sachen aus dem verkauf geplatzt
aber vielleicht können wir zum abschluss
nochmal klären ich weiß nicht wie viele
leute dich das gefragt haben wie das für
uns beide nein war es für unsere
freundschaften challenge bei der sendung
mitzumachen und für unsere freundschaft
unsere freundschaft ist auf einem
nächsten
next level also ich muss sagen dass ich
dann halt mit gemacht habe weil du dabei
bist ja und weil wir eine woche hamburg
hatten ja und wir wurden immer in der
sendung immer gefragt wollt ihr denn
nicht gewinnen und wie ist es für euch
und wie es der rivalität gedanke als
eigentlich immer beide in die sendung in
hamburg zum spaß vielleicht zeigen sie
ist willig in kiefer gebrochen haben ja
aber vielleicht schneiden ist raus und
ich glaube sie schneiden
aber es war schon recht jederzeit wieder
machen will ich auch mit dir ich träume
davon angelina einmal mit ihr zu machen
gruppe 2
wir brauchen auch zusammen
also heute soll das ist auf jeden fall
aber mal fertig das kann ein bisschen
herum dann war das popcorn unterrichten
hier weißt du was ich hab mir gedacht
wir richten eine schöne große platte an
ya
neck platz richtigen fleck klasse hatte
mal ich hab da was
habe einfach meine wohnzimmertisch dabei
sehr toll
und den wohnzimmertisch dachte ich mir
richten wir jetzt schön an sollen wir
noch den kurven schneiden oh ja den
kuchen genau dem schneiden wir jetzt
noch kurz und dann kommt jetzt alles
drauf entsteht hier eine schöne snack
platte
aus dem hocker und
so gut ist dass sich der hocker
eigentlich
ist das nicht er hat raúl brauch soll
soll ich auch noch hier die werte würden
acht wir hier fand das so da sind die
maiskolben ja er wollte für mich nicht
gewehrt ich kann ja das ist meine
erfüllung
mein hobby
also lasst alles anrichten
die nachos
die verbrennen
juni
egal
mir so und so eine unterlage
es gut aus wow ok dann bricht man jetzt
alles an
[Musik]
so sieht mega aus oder richtig richtig
super das ist ich würde mal sagen für
jeden was dabei und die gesamte
nachbarschaft kann kommen sagt nicht
eine wahre größe oder
hasst sie ja die beide aus gebracht wird
wie inspektor gadget ja ist ja ich hätte
unser deutsches
duo lag dann kann die sendung beginnen
genau also ihr habt die rezepte für die
drinks meister la
maiskolben nachos käsekuchen tipp für
alles ihr habt die rezepte in der app
und die könnte genau zu sagen wir packen
jetzt meinen politisch wieder mit rüber
ins wohnzimmer wie viele leute tragen
aber so ein gabelstapler 2 oder
murat kirchenbücher und
wenn wir dies noch aus als wenn
eine hausrat und wir gehen jetzt rüber
und genießen mit euch die sendung und
freuen uns mit beck wir haben uns
richtig auf die tube
[Musik]
okay aber
gut gekocht wir haben sehr gut gekocht
das sieht unfassbar lecker aus ich freue
mich tierisch auf die folge alle sind
mit dabei
heute
gar nicht mehr sagen schalten wir ein
wir schalten jetzt ihr solltet ihr ab
bereitet schnell eure snacks zu und dann
geht es heute abend los und wir sind
echt schon auf euer feedback gespannt
genau feuert uns an und ich bin ganz
gespannt was ihr zu dem ergebnis am ende
sagt von der folge ja ich auch und daher
wir quasi eine shoppingplattform haben
und keine bösen kommentare auf facebook
wollen kommentiert einfach unter diesem
video und unter unter unseren postings
ja lass ganz viel liebe da ist das was
die welt braucht hängt
ja dann muss sie jetzt dass es daran
geht da ja okay was ist
denn
hier ein und ihr solltet ihr auch
über den 31
diese woche
kommen kann ist noch lang besteck
genannt
[Musik]
hätte einen schönen guten morgen am
schönsten tag der ganzen woche konnten
[Musik]